MMM.
You've made it to the last lesson in native link.com series on using the IPA to
pronounce another language.
This time I'm going to build on the previous videos that introduced vowels,
consonants and syllables and move on to features that apply to longer units of
speech.
First off,
it's important to consider that when we record speech or listened to speech,
we don't actually find things like breaks between words or pauses between
sentences.
We don't hear punctuation or capital letters.
Instead we hear very fluid stream of sounds.
There's a linguistic term for that stream of sounds.
An utterance.
An utterance is a chunk of spoken language.
The concept of utterances focuses on speech instead of squeezing spoken language
into categories proper to written language like words and sentences and
paragraphs.
This plays into phonetic transcriptions.
In Ipa.
We don't need to use things like punctuation marks,
word breaks or line breaks in IPA.
That also leads to another observation about speech.
Speakers don't make a clear divisions between sounds between the individual
phonemes when they're spoken out loud.
Phonemes that are pronounced next to each other tend to become more alike.
This is a process known as assimilation.
Here's an example of a simulation with the phoneme n.
The N in the word lane has the alveolar nasal mm,
but the n in language has the Vilar nasal
notice that comes before the [inaudible] stop.
This n has assimilated to the Vilar sound that comes after it.
I'm telling you that and are two different sounds in the words lane and
language.
However,
if you're an English speaker,
you probably think that these two sounds are simply versions of the same sound.
They're both n sounds.
This points to an abstract concept.
The concept of aloe phones versus underlying phonemes and these examples mm and
mm are two allophones of the same underlying phony.
The abstract phoneme is n,
but it's realized in different contexts by different allophones.
Allophone is a Greek word for other sound and that's really the way that a
speaker of a language here's different sounds as versions of the same sound.
We can visually distinguish phonemes from allophones in IPA by enclosed AME
closing allophones in brackets.
These two sounds and close to in brackets are different allophones of that same
phoneme and speech isn't just phonemes strung together into syllables and
utterances.
There are other features.
One other feature is known as accent stress.
Accent involves saying one syllable of a word louder than the surrounding
syllables.
We do this in English with words that have a fixed accent.
For instance,
in the word hotel,
the second syllable is pronounced louder than the first.
On the other hand,
in the word hostel,
the first syllable is louder than the second.
So in hotel,
the second syllable is given a stress accent.
It's weighted stress.
Accident is indicated in Ipa by a small,
straight apostrophe before the stressed syllable like this.
Notice that the syllable breaks,
symbolist dropped when the stress accent is added.
Words can have a pitch accent instead.
In some languages,
pitch involves raising or lowering the tone as in music.
For instance,
the ancient Greek word out toss as a high pitch on the last syllable.
Well,
the word [inaudible] has a high pitch on the first syllable.
The other syllables have a lower pitch where it's can be distinguished that way.
We can represent basic pitch changes in Ipa with an acute accent above high tone
valves and a grave accent above low tone valves.
We've been applying these features at the level of syllables and words.
What if we apply those features like languages routinely due to the level of
utterances in sentences?
When we get to that level,
we can see that we use stress in English to differentiate.
I didn't go versus I didn't go versus I didn't go.
I'm using stress to convey emphasis or to nuance the meaning.
We can consider intonation.
Similarly,
English speakers,
regular leaves intonation at the level of a sentence to ask a question.
You raise your voice at the end of a sentence to ask a question,
right and intonation lowers at the end of a typical statement.
I've just given you examples of prosody,
the application of features like intonation and stress at the level of an entire
phrase or an entire utterance rather than at the level of a single phoneme or a
single syllable.
I've now covered the basics of fouls,
consonants,
syllables and prosody.
You can start to use your understanding of the IPA as you learn languages.
Check out the web page or workbook from our practice and move on to the intro to
phonology for a deeper understanding of how pronunciation works.
All the best on your journeys with IPA.
And thanks for learning with me.